كما اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه من الجانب
الاخر ان قواتها احبطت هجمات للجيش
الاوكرانيه في مقاطعه خيرسون ولوجان وقال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره ايغور كناشنكوف عند
القوات الروسيه دمرت مستودعي اسلحه بعين
للجيش الاوكراني فيزا
ودمرت ايضا خزان للوقود في ميكرويف
كريزيما للقوات الاوكرانيه وتم القضاء على
اكثر من 100 عسكريين اوكرانيا استهدفت
قواتنا سبعه مواقع قياده اوكرانيه في خارج
كيف ودنيا وخيرسون دمرنا مستودعيني
للصواريخ وقضاء في المدفعيه
اضافه الى منشئه لتخزين وقود المعدات
العسكريه التابعه للقوات الاوكرانيه في
بيكو لايف كما دمرنا محطه ايرادار لانظمه
الصواريخ الاوكرانيه اس 300 المضاده
للطائرات في كرامته
وفي اثناء روسيا ما تزال منفتحه على
المحادثات مع اوكرانيا وبشعر ما نشرته
صحيفه
عن اجراء مستشار الامن القومي الامريكي
جيك سوليفان محادثات سريه مع الجانب
الروسي اعتبر الكريب لان وسائل الاعلام
البريطانيه والامريكيه تورد الكثيره مما
وصفها بالمعلومات الكاذبه
معنا من دوناتكم مراسل الجزيره امين
درغامي ومعنى من كرامات مراسل الجزيره
عامر لافي في هذه الحرب منذ بدايتها دائما
هناك رويتنا نبدا بالروايه الروسيه
لمجريات الاحداث في مختلفه الجبهات مع
امين درغامي
زين القصف والقذف المتبادل ما زال متواصلا
منذ الليله الماضيه في المناطق القريبه من
خط التماس هنا في مدينه دونياسك ايضا في
مدينه سينغاتا المجاوره وفي جور الافكار
وفي بلده مارينكا كل هذه المناطق تشهد
قصفا مدفعيا وصاروخيا متبادلا بين
الجانبين اصوات هذا القصف تصل الى وسط
مدينه دونيازك حيث نحن بل وقذائف القصر
ايضا وصلت الى مركز مدينه دنيا
حينما استهدف مبنى اداره السكك الحديديه
الليله الماضيه وهناك الحريق ما زال
متواصلا وفرق ما زال تحاول اخماده همم
طبعا همم معارك ايضا ضاريه تدور على طول
خط الجبهه هنا في اقليم جمباز شمالا من
منطقه
مرورا بضخموت وايضا في المناطق ال- ال-
القريبه من جورلوك ومايورس بالتحديد وصولا
الى منطقه المطار هنا في مدينه دونياس
كنوبا ايضا الى مدينه اوغليدار ومحيطها
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اليوم قالت بان
خسائر الفرقه 155 تابعه لاسطول همم
المحيطه الهادئ همم تعد عاديه وان هذه
الفرقه تقاتل في محور قرب مدينه اونجليدار
وذلك في رد على الجدل الذي اسير منذ امس
حول ما قيل انها خسائر كبيره تعرضت لها
هذه الفرقه التي تقاتل في محور اوجليدار
وكانت هناك مطالب القياده العسكريه
الروسيه من اجل فتح تحقيق وايضا اعاده
النظر في تلك الخطه العسكريه من اجل
السيطره على اوليدار في محور افديف كما
زالت القوات المواليه لروسيا تحاول اقتحام
دفاعات الجيش الاوكراني باتجاه بلده
بيرفوما والتي يحاول الان المولون لروسيا
سيطر عليها
لاحكام طوق على خطوط الامداد
والدعم العسكري باتجاه مدينه افديفكا همم
طبعا الوزاره اليوم الوطني تحدثت عن
استهدافات في كل من خيرصون
وزباروجراميتوس اسلحه جديده وصلت همم او
في طريقها همم فيما يتعلق همم
اوكرانيا تسلمت انظمه شمس همم ماذا يقول
لاكرونيون عن همم هذه الصفقه هذه الصواريخ
طبعا كانوا يطالبون بها كثيرا في الماضي
نعم زين طبعا الاوكرانيون يصلهم الاسلحه
المتطوره منذ فتره وهو ما قلب الى نوعا
ماذا يعني اقول
كفتين المعادله هنا في اقليم جمباز تحقيقا
تعلم ان القوات الروسيه انسحبت بشكل مفاجئ
ودراماتيكي من شرق غار كيف ومن شمال
دونيتس بل ان القوات الاوكرانيه تمكنت من
استعاده 9 من بلدات مقاطعه لوغانستان
بالكامل كانت قد سقطت بيد القوات الروسيه
الان المعارك هناك تجري على محور مهم
ومحور سبوتوفا كريمنا والقوات الوكانيه
تتحدث يوميا عنها وعلى الرغم من ان هناك
مراوح منذ فتره بسيطه الاعتبار ان القوات
الروسيه قوه من ااه الدفاعاتها هناك لانه
هناك تقدم كبير وحديث اليوم من مصادر
عسكريه ان هناك عدد كبير من الاسرى سقط
وبيد القوات الاوكرانيه جول هؤلاء الاسرهم
من القوات التي حجزتهم روسيا مؤخرا من
قوات الاحتياط وارسالتهم هذا المحور
وبالتالي الاسلحه الحديثه تصل بشكل مستمر
انظمه الدفاع الجوي زين هي ليست مهمه فقط
هنا هي مهمه لكل اوكرانيا مهمه لكياب
ومهمه للمدن الكبيره التي تستهدف بشكل
مستمر تعلم القوات الروسيه مؤخرا بدات
باستراتيجيا ضرب المواقع البني مواقع
البنيه التحتيه وتحديدا محطات توليد
الكهرباء ولا اعلم ان الشتاء القارص الذي
يعصف دائما بهذه الدوله هو يعني يخيف
الجميع الان على اعتبار ان هناك مشاكل
كبيره في الكهرباء الان العاصمه كيا في
تقطع عنها الكهرباء يوميا لعده ساعات هنا
ايضا في اقليم بن باسو وبالتالي هذه
الانظمه الصاروخيه ضروريه بالنسبه
لاوكرانيا لحمايه اجوائدها ولحمايه هذه
البنيه التحتيه لكي يتمكن الشعب الاوكراني
من استمرار خلال فصل هذا الشتاء لكن بخصوص
الاسلحه كما ذكرنا تصل الان اليوم وهناك
المعلومات التي وصلتنا عن ان هذه الاسلحه
التي تم من خلالها استهداف عده مواقع
وتقول القوات الاوكرانيه بانها قتلت
العديد من الجنود الروس في عده مواقع هنا
في اقليم دون باس بواسطه هذه الاسلحه
من دوناتس مراسل الجزيره من درغامي شكرا
جزيلا لكم معنا